bienvenidos nuevamente finalmente
estamos usando la transformada de
laplace para resolver un problema y la
primera parte de este problema trata
acerca de esta ecuación diferencial
bastante directa y sé que hábitat les
puede parecer un poco frustrante el ver
todo este desarrollo ya que este es
bastante fácil de resolver por la
ecuación característica pero quiero
mostrarles que podemos usar esta
transformada de laplace para resolver
este tipo de problemas ya que más
adelante veremos tipos de problemas para
los cuales los métodos tradicionales no
nos sirven mucho para resolverlos pero
bueno terminamos haciendo todas estas
ecuaciones medio densas usamos las
propiedades de las derivadas de las
transformadas de la plaza y terminamos
realizando bastante álgebra para llegar
a esto a la transformada de la plastia
que es igual a todo esto aplicamos la
está normada de la clase en ambos lados
para calcularlo de maneras hebraica y
nuestra tarea en este vídeo es encontrar
qué función
nos da una transformada de laplace que
se parezca a este resultado y
esencialmente lo que tratamos de hacer
es encontrar la transformada inversa de
la plaza de ambos lados de esta ecuación
para encontrar la transformada inversa
de y podemos decir que va a ser
ahora está en forma de inversa de la
plaza
de estos 2 s 13 entre s cuadrada más 5 s
eventualmente aprenderemos cuál es la
definición formal de la transformada
inversa de la plaza como pasamos del
dominio de s al dominio de t o como
pasamos del dominio de la frecuencia al
dominio del tiempo ahorita no nos vamos
a preocupar por eso lo que queremos
hacer ahorita es tomar esto y dejarlo de
una forma que podamos reconocer que esa
es la transformada de laplace de algo y
a partir de ahí podremos encontrar el
valor de y vamos a tratar de hacerlo lo
que vamos a usar es algo que quizás no
hayan usado desde álgebra 2 me parece
que ahí es en ese nivel cuando lo ocupan
octavo noveno décimo grado dependiendo y
es hasta que vemos ecuaciones
diferenciales donde se encuentran
algunos o vamos a usar la expansión de
fracciones parciales y voy a poner aquí
algo para recordarles de qué se trata y
en caso de que no lo recuerden vamos a
factorizar el denominador de esto y ya
se dan cuenta hacia donde quiero llegar
si factor hizo el denominador voy a
obtener
+ 2 x s más 3
y ahora lo que queremos hacer es
reescribir esta fracción como la suma
de dos fracciones parciales y creo que
es por eso que esto se llama la
expansión de fracciones parciales
vamos a expresar esto como la suma de a
entre esas dos más ve
/ s más atrás
si podemos hacer esto y a lo mejor
ustedes ya están haciendo la operación
en sus mentes sabemos sabemos que estas
cosas son la transformada de la plaza de
funciones que ya conocemos y vamos a
revisar esto en un momento para
recordarlo pero bueno veamos cómo
calcular a ive
si fuéramos a sumar a ive vamos a
hacerlo aquí a un lado
si les llevamos un denominador común o
como un denominador
que sería este
es más dos por semestres
que sería bueno x 3
s más 3 y esto que estoy escribiendo
aquí es lo mismo que estoy poniendo acá
solo dando un común denominador si se
dan cuenta ustedes pueden cancelar estos
dos términos y ahora vamos a agregar la
parte que corresponde a b que esto lo
ves en otro color más bueno si tenemos
esto como denominador podemos
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por s más 2 para obtener
x s + 2 b
y esto debe ser igual a esta otra cosa
lo único que he hecho aquí es sumar
estas fracciones no he hecho nada más
complejo esto es álgebra básica pero
esto va a ser igual a todo esto
lo escribimos aquí 12 s 13
todo esto entre ese 2 por ese 3
ahora noten que en todas las ecuaciones
diferenciales la parte más densa o más
pesada siempre es la parte de álgebra
así que ahora lo que hacemos es
encontrar coincidencias podemos agrupar
los términos de ese y encontrar que
estos términos deben ser iguales en
estos lados así que tenemos a más de s
+ 3 a 2 ven que debe ser igual a 2s más
el coeficiente de las heces debe ser
igual a 2 por lo que más bien debe ser
igual a 2
más bien igualados
y del lado derecho tenemos 3 a 2 b
aquí este 13 no se nota muy bien así que
lo voy a volver a escribir 13
si no se puede confundir con un ave y no
quiero confundirlos así que del lado
derecho tengo 3
3 a 2 b que debe ser igual a 13
ahora tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas y sé que habitan a lo mejor
están un poco cansados pero verán que
vale la pena ya que al final van a
resolver algo con la transformada de la
plaza multiplicamos la ecuación de
arriba por 2 o bueno x menos 2 - 2 a
menos 2 b va a ser igual a menos 4 y
aquí agregamos las dos ecuaciones y nos
queda que a es igual
estas se cancelan a va a ser igual a 9
si es igual a 9 aquí va a ser igual b a
pues b va a ser igual a 9 más algo que
debe ser igual a 2 b tiene que ser igual
a menos 7 y ya hemos simplificado
bastante esto ya que ahora podemos
reescribir toda esta ecuación como la
transformada de la plaza
de iu
la transformada de la clase ya que es
igual a a 19 entre s más 2 - 7 entre s
más 3
otra manera de escribir esto podemos
escribirlo así que es igual a 9 x 1 en
13 + 2 menos 7 x 1 / s + 3 porque nos
tomamos la molestia de hacer esto bueno
yo espero que ustedes reconozcan esta
parte que es la segunda transformada de
la plaza que calculamos en vídeos
anteriores esta fue la segunda
transformada de laplace que encontramos
y cuál es esta bueno vamos a escribirla
aquí y es la tensionada de la plaza
aporte que es igual a 1 entre s menos
esta fue la segunda transformada de las
que calculamos así que si queremos
encontrar que esto es la transformada de
la plaza de algo vamos a calcular la
transforma de inversa de la plaza
eso significa que esa es la transformada
de la plaza de yale
que es igual a 9 por la transformada de
la plaza de esto y si vemos este patrón
diremos que ésta es a menos 2 es la
transformada de la plaza de al menos 2
por t
espero que esto tenga sentido si ustedes
toman esto y lo sustituyen acá van a
obtener este valor 1 en 3 + 2 y
permíteme quitar algo de aquí porque voy
a necesitar más espacio
vamos a borrar esta parte de acá esto lo
dejo porque todavía no voy a usar y
ahora tenemos menos 7
x esto que es la transformada de la
plástica pues sustituimos el mismo
patrón va a ser la transformada de la
plaza
adame nostresport e simplemente estamos
sustituyendo el patrón aquí si ustedes
van al nuestra tabla de transformadas de
la plaza y encuentran esto van a ver que
pues pueden sustituir esta parte por
esto y van a encontrar cuál es la
transformada de la plage correspondiente
así que aquí nada más sustituyen el
valor de a dejando que hace igual a
menos 3 quedando
a la menos 3 t y ahora podemos tomar la
transformada inversa de la plaza aunque
antes de eso sabemos que esto es así
debido a que el operador de la
transformada de la plaza es un operador
lineal y ahora sí puedo borrar esto de
aquí sabemos que el operador de la
transformada de la plaza es un operador
lineal y normalmente no realizaremos
todos estos pasos pero ahora quiero que
les quede muy claro todo lo que estamos
haciendo así que podemos decir que todo
esto es igual que la transformada de la
plaza
al menos 237 y al menos 3 t y ahora
tenemos algo interesante la trama de la
plaza de iu es igual a la transformada
de la plaza de esto si este es el caso
entonces ya va a ser igual a 9 x
al menos 2 de menos 7 y a la menos 3 t
la formada de la plaza realmente es una
transformación de 11 si yo tomo una
función y luego la transformada de la
plaza y obtengo la transformada inversa
de la plaza la única función que va a
ser resultado es la función original es
decir que ningún par de funciones
diferentes tendrá la misma transformada
aquí hay un par de cosas que hay que
tener en mente noten que tenemos esto
que podría parecer una ecuación
característica y tenemos que resolver de
todas maneras un sistema de ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas son ambas cosas que
tenemos que hacer cuando estamos
resolviendo el valor inicial de una
ecuación característica tradicional pero
aquí todo ocurre el mismo tiempo
esto estuvo bastante denso porque
tuvimos que hacer toda esta parte de las
fracciones parciales pero es bastante
legal la transformada de la plaza no
sirve para algo útil y en el siguiente
vídeo de hecho voy a hacer una ecuación
no homogénea donde la transformada de la
plaza se aplica igual de bien ahí es una
teoría un poco más consistente para
resolver ecuaciones diferenciales en
lugar de estar adivinando soluciones nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo